by
rick mueller
he's
the senior manager for advanced
microsystems group at sandia national
labs and he's also the
deputy director of the of the qsa
uh
the the other um quantum institute um
uh that's that's funded through the
through the doe
now rick is um
uh rick is
leading the silicon-based quantum
computing effort at uh at sandia
national lab so uh
over to you rick
thank you very much umesh um and uh
thanks to dan for a great introduction
to
another center that is largely centered
around berkeley
i'm going to talk about a doe funded
center called the quantum systems
accelerator
that is led by
irfan siddiqui at um uh lawrence
berkeley national laboratories and at uh
in the physics department at university
of california at berkeley um and i'm the
deputy director at sandia um
and um
and so
in addition to
sandia and lawrence berkeley national
laboratories um we have a really
remarkable group of
of partners um in the quantum systems
accelerator
and since stan read his mission
statement um i will read ours um the the
quantum systems accelerator seeks to
catalyze national leadership in quantum
information science to co-design the
algorithms quantum devices and
engineering solutions needed to deliver
certified quantum advantage in
department of energy scientific
applications
so
um so again like the ciqc
and unlike necessarily all of the
other five doe hubs in this area
we do focus on on quantum computing
um and um a great partner to us um in
this endeavor is the simons institute um
we use the expertise that the simons
institute has uh both uh to to further
our research goals um and also for our
uh workforce and ecosystem work uh about
which i will uh speak to uh in a few
minutes
so so the the metaphor we used for
um
how we are trying to identify and solve
problems in the quantum systems
accelerator was this kind of picture
that you know often if you're hiking in
the mountains you don't know the path up
the highest mountain until you're
standing on the peaks of some of the
foothills
and what the quantum systems accelerator
wants to do is stand on the
smaller peak of
noisy intermediate scale quantum devices
and start to understand what the most
fruitful pathways to take from those
devices are
to to reach this this mythical um
it's not mythical so so to reach um our
ultimate goal of of making uh fault
tolerant quantum computing devices
so um we um try to identify what the
biggest obstacles to progress
in these areas are
and it will come as no surprise to this
audience
but but these are that quantum systems
are imperfect and have limited coherence
and fidelity um and so one of our goals
is to develop um optimize noise-aware
nisk hardware
additionally it's challenging to control
quantum systems uh and when you can
control quantum systems um those
controls are often not uh extensible um
and so another major effort for us is to
develop high fidelity modular
control techniques for these
and then the last two directly touch on
uh work that is also
explored by the simon's institute
in general um we do not know
the full domain of meaningful
applications um certainly that this
hardware can do use with a certified
quantum advantage um and so we are
exploring analog and digital quantum
devices we also lack the protocols to
quantify and benchmark the hardware that
we have
and so to to understand uh when a
computation is actually quantum supreme
um and so again the the the goal is to
develop those techniques to to identify
quantum supremacy um and to benchmark
nascent quantum processors as they're
developed
i apologize for the eye chart here um
um i wanted to give you an impression of
the scope of the work that were that
we're undertaking by the quantum in the
quantum systems accelerator um uh we
start in the bottom here um with with
programmable quantum systems so so so
these are working quantum quantum
devices that we can start to put knobs
on and understand how can we control
them how can we uh do quantum operations
with them um we focus in our center on
uh superconducting
trapped ion and neutral atom qubits here
um and obviously we're also deeply
concerned with the
um
the materials and the interfacial limits
to the coherence in these devices as
well
um now on on on top of those
programmable quantum quantum systems we
want to build um
engineered systems that let us build
um
prototype devices that let us explore
the limits of these techniques um and so
in our first phase
we are exploring um
extending the integration of
superconducting quantum devices um to 3d
integration um exploring uh techniques
to couple uh linear ion traps together
to make
2d like uh interconnected
quantum processors there
and to explore the the possibility of of
neutral atoms by making uh larger and
more extensible neutral atom quantum
emulators
and then at the end of the day
we want to be able to
have
noise aware error mitigation
hardware and noise aware compilation uh
that can then ultimately um help us
understand um
um how to benchmark these devices and
then what types of mathematical and
physical simulations uh can we achieve
with these devices
okay so we are already seeing science
emerge from the quantum systems
accelerator um that
gives us great hope for for the future
of this endeavor um
in the upper left what we see is a
recent publication in science by uh john
bollinger and his co-workers in boulder
on
using penning traps to make
two-dimensional arrays of neutral atoms
that can serve as quantum sensors for
very fine-tuned electric
field sensing with these with these
pinning traps
similarly out of the leukem group at
harvard
we have a very recent nature publication
where the leukem group has demonstrated
the ability to
first load imperfect arrays of neutral
atoms um
get up to 256 atom arrays
and then rearrange and repack those
arrays um and and do computations on
those arrays um with relatively high
fidelity that
really pushes the limits to uh what we
thought was possible in the near term
with the neutral atom platform
uh and similarly i wanted to cite
something out of uh umash and norm yao
and their co-workers
a recent publication in physical review
b
um
shows um very promising performance by
the rigorous renormalization group first
order phase transitions and topological
phases
and this is compared to techniques that
we've known have been useful for a long
time
um
like the density matrix neuralization
group um and um and in particular this
study shows um much more robustness in
in sensitive areas um of
of in critical points in sensitive areas
in these phase transitions uh that the
rigorous funeral
renormalization group shows
um
that the the density matrix normal
renormalization group does not show easy
for me to say
it's about five minutes remaining thank
you
so in addition to the technical goals
we have broad goals to
enhance and nurture the quantum
ecosystem
this involves
developing a workforce for for the
quantum future
engaging with industrial research groups
and building a diverse and an inclusive
culture both within our center and in
the broader quantum workforce
i'll just note here that the simons
institute is a large part of our uh
efforts in workforce development um our
goal is to um use the expertise at the
simons institute in hosting uh deep
dives into
technical topics in the theory of
computation
and we're planning to host
summer programs here
deeper research pods and other programs
that we'll focus on and
elucidate
key qsa problem sets
and then finally since this is an
industry day i wanted to say a word
about our industrial collaborations
we have we have three levels of
industrial engagement that we're looking
at right now um uh the first are
created driven research partnerships
when we and an industrial partner can
identify a key problem that we would
like to pursue in collaboration and so
we've got a number of these with
different uh industrial partners right
now
in addition to this we have a broader
group of technology partners
who don't have individual research
problems that we're working on
collaboratively
but whom we keep apprised of usa
research um and we
meet with regularly to understand what
their concerns and needs are for the
quantum industry
and then as we develop um
intellectual property
and other technologies within the qsa
partners
it's our goal to understand how best to
start new companies or otherwise share
that technology with the broader area
so hopefully that gives you
some idea of what the quantum systems
accelerator is doing
my email address is r muller at
sandia.gov
and if you're interested
please reach out to me
and i will
see that your questions uh meet the
appropriate people there
so
beyond that
thank you to umesh and the simons
institute for
inviting me to give this talk and thank
you for your attention
umesh you may still be muted
uh hi can you hear me
yes we got her okay great yeah
okay thanks thanks rick um so i just
wanted to say um if if there are any
questions uh at this point for either
dan or for rick
[Music]
there may be a minute or so for that a
minute or two
while we set up for the panel
then uh
i have a question can you hear me
yeah hey andre just out of curiosity so
i think you mentioned um
you know all of this a lot of this
workforce development programs that you
are
that ciqc is kind of supporting
and they all are targeted at you know
undergrads grads
have you been thinking
about high school
uh students and getting them engaged
in quantum computing and yeah good
question so um
i'd say
i'd say within our center honestly not
so much um across the entire um
uh
qlci landscape there is sort of a lot of
interest in this uh q through 12
um idea of of bringing
quantum education
i guess they must mean all the way down
to kindergarten i'm not really sure what
it is we're gonna teach them here's your
toy you know it isn't here um
but but no that's not really that's not
really been been our specialization uh
to this point
um
i don't know that that's maybe that's
that's a good enough that's a good
enough answer there's a lot of great
efforts uh in this area that we can you
know we can probably learn about but we
have to
we have to pick where we want to focus
our our uh our attention and that's not
been where it is
i will say
unsolicited that in addition to
undergraduates and graduates and
postdocs
and although the qsa is also not
focusing on high school students we are
experimenting with outreach to community
colleges as ways of developing
talent in people that may not be reached
in
traditional four-year universities
oh mesh i think you're muted
all right can you hear me none
yes
okay sorry i was just going to jump into
a moment and and
since andrea is
has
has this
has been working
towards this goal of
education for i don't know undergrads
and high school students true
through something that you founded cube
rate you want to say a word about it
oh um yeah i guess it's mostly so far
been with high school students really
and i guess one program that we ran
this summer
which was uh i think you know
quite nice for the students was uh
we basically reached out to undergrads
um
you know across different universities
who are already naturally interested in
quantum these are you know undergrads
that are involved in quantum computing
clubs and that sort of thing
and we basically you know sort of
got them to teach
high school students in groups of say 20
or 30 students a relatively small
class
for a period of you know eight to ten
weeks
um and you know this was all free and
and
i i think the high school students got
got a lot of it um
out of it
yeah i will say now that you mentioned
it that the qsa did a two-week
mentorship program
through the jsti
that did
connect high school students interested
in quantum
with
quantum scientists at lawrence berkeley
and at sandia labs
just to talk about you know what your
day is like if you are a quantum
scientist um not that there's any single
answer to that but you know just to kind
of give them an idea of what kinds of
preparation they'd need uh and what life
is like in this area
yeah because i think high school
students nowadays are
are very uh
precocious and and you know a lot of
them wanna
you know of course not not you know all
people are interested in quantum but
uh i think given that quantum is you
know right at this intersection between
you know math computer science physics
uh it can be very um
stimulating yeah
it's cool yes
um a great uh thanks andre and thanks
again dan and rick for
really great talks
so now we can move on to the
to the second panel um
i'll introduce the
the